ich habe auch von mir meine meinung dass
ich dich hübsch finde und mein schlaf
nur gerade auf schiffen ich dich halt
nicht so hübsch nicht willkommen beim
ein video ich hab heute nach wirklich
seeberger war sehr langer zeit von
bestimmt vier wochen rhesus erst mal
wieder mein drängen dabei und wer uns
heute was besonderes überlegt der seite
von mir gewohnt ich bringe immer
besondere videos und fahren hat sich
jeder von uns das haben schon mehrere
user gemacht allerdings immer nur unter
dem namen so meine freunde in meinem
bruder meine schwester bewertet andere
youtuber nein wir in xativa wie
angedacht wir wollen dieses alte kind
zur hot or not zum facebook war auch mal
ist ein markstein mannschaft nie
mitgemacht
ich wollte auch gar nicht mitmachen auf
jeden fall haben wir uns jeder vier
jungs überhaupt fertig 44 weibliche
youtuber raus noch für mich und ich habe
von ich hab mir vier männliche raus
sucht für wien und dann spielen wir halt
dieses hot or not und müsse sein ob das
unser tipp ist oder nicht so gut
wir wollen gar nicht lange lagern und es
wird sagen wir fangen sofort mal an
bei vier millionen 322 1830 live gibt
parteien also wird kein leben kenne
dieses spiel immer wenn man so macht man
immer wenn sie reinkommt damit dass man
so schlagen weißt du und wenn sie so den
finger rein macht und ich wieder bei
fackel darf ich drei mal schlagen
und wenn sie das aber schafft und darf
die mich keiner schlagen also gefunden
fingern zu demonstrationen dürfen bis
hierhin ich würde sagen wir von objekt
wirklich wichtige stellung bekommen
schnick schnack schnuck
ich hab jetzt nämlich zwei
internationale youtuber und zwei
deutsche ok ich würde sagen du auch die
tu ich würde sagen wir fangen jetzt mit
einem internationalen angst den kennt
man eigentlich weiß nicht ob du dich
vielleicht mal für medien und fernsehen
dem herzlichen art auch wenn der
wahltermin wie oft bist du nicht so gut
dass der größte youtuber der weltweit
über 50 millionen abonnenten jährige
scott schweden macht aber englischen
konnte australien malaysia auf jeden
fall hat aber ich stehe auf diese weise
ein bisschen du musst immer dabei ich
kenne sie noch nicht lange so ich gucke
ich meine wunden abfahren kannst du
alles oder australien das irgendwie ihr
ex freund oder bislang wurden haben der
machtgierige blogs gucken wir mal an
benutzer zeit um ein bisschen mein
englisch aufzubessern hat auch dass die
aids zu können hallo mein name ist alex
einleitete wetter hier erwartet sie aber
finde ich auf jeden fall ist eine süße
würde ich heiraten wenn die jetzt sagen
fragen würde ob ich etwas weg ich bin
dran
wie findest du denn hier ein paar schöne
augen schöne augen richtig deswegen also
hat im rat ich weiß nicht wer natürliche
hübsches auch blond bin ich ja
eigentlich ganz gut mädchen also ich
würde auf jeden fall sagen soll man
sagen hat in den ersten noch mal die
erste ich bin ich schon alle motto wir
machen weiter what do you think about
den hier zu 100 sicher rapper
[Musik]
ich finde mal in seiner populärsten
häufig findet der macht wirklich kein
konsens wind ist eine super person und
was mir als erstem aufwerten großen vier
also wird jetzt erst mal wagen nicht so
ein typ also noch gemeint du bist du
bist gerade oberflächlich meinung sagen
nur auf das unter typ ist oder nicht tun
um meine meinung
oberflächlich zu tun ich habe auch von
mir meine meinung dass ich die
rückstände und mannschaft nur gerade auf
schiffen amerikanischer blogger wäre sie
ganz genau ich bin jetzt auch wieder in
amerika ich doch die wird so 28 oder so
oder sagen wir okay aber das darf
natürlich auch zu hast schöne augen vor
allem auf dem bild die augen
wer die augen heraus ich meine würdigen
wird kein junge oder ich kann sagen wie
die halt verleihen dass er ist die
berühmt
zwei millionen ja das ist natürlich
überhaupt nicht auf meiner schule
willkommen zum letzten hab ich mir dann
noch einmal sehr viel mühe gegeben
kennst du denn hier und liefen zu den
gewöhnlichen geklingelt so was wir
zusagen erst mal wird zu sagen hot or
not ist dein typ oder nicht so flott wie
findest du deine tattoo was wir zu sagen
würde ich mir sonst machen wir hier
unter fast nichts davon wenn ich mir so
hier sind atommacht hier so runter so
und dann mache ich mir noch hier hinten
ein
und damit hatten mein volk aber dafür
ist meine eltern sagen will und was ich
dir so nah hinter dir hängen
der hat aber ich glaube ich jetzt blaue
habe ich weiter bin ich klar schluss
machen wir nicht mehr blaue haare machen
würde
gute idee nur in der nacht auf der
komplett
die polizei super ich sind auf jeden
fall wieder werke laut nicht gemacht
baby ist eine schöne die schöne
sympathisches junges mädel was ab und zu
auch mal blaue haare dann wieder
regenbogenfarben ein grüner dann pinkl
aber ich kann nichts gegen sagen ich
finde auf jeden fall mehr attraktiv
sagen ja auch dass du manchmal wenn du
so ein bisschen so ähnlich aussieht so
zum beispiel auf dem bild wenn du ne
sander aufsetzen würde ist und ich sogar
einstellen wird es wäre jetzt war also
könnte man vielleicht gewisse so ganz
leichte züge von ähnlichkeit erkennen
aber ich finde ich natürlich tausende
hübsche also das was mit diesem video
brauchen natürlich es hat euch ein
bisschen unterhalten und über eure
meinung als mädchen schreibt aber in die
kommentare
auf welchen youtuber ihr extrem abfahrt
auf mich jetzt natürlich termin gekommen
mach das mal und als junge genau so und
ich bin mal gespannt schlechtem ein paar
kommentare durch und mal sehen welcher
user so die meisten punkte sammelt ja
ansonsten sehen wir uns am morgigen
montag um 19 uhr wieder volksmusik und
instagram und gemeint wegen auf was
alles in dem video beschreibung